LASZLO BOCK: OK.
Terrific.
Well, thanks, everybody, for
showing up live, showing up
on the stream for this
Authors at Google talk.
And I could not be
more excited to be
introducing our guests today.
So I'll read a little
bit to make sure I
don't miss the good stuff.
Although, there's so much,
we could spend a whole hour
on this.
JACK WELCH: We don't
need to do that.
LASZLO BOCK: Just a little.
Just a little.
Some people may not
have heard of you two.
JACK WELCH: OK.
LASZLO BOCK: So just in case.
We're thrilled to host
Jack and Suzy Welch today.
Jack was chairman and
CEO of General Electric
during a revolutionary
time in its history,
a time when it went
from a great company
to the greatest company.
And the management practices
that Jack instilled
and the team he built have
been lauded ever since.
And it's a once in a generation
kind of company, an institution
that he built and created.
Suzy, an author and journalist,
former editor-in-chief
of "The Harvard
Business Review,"
a keen judge of people and
talent, and a fantastic writer.
They've been partners
and collaborators
for over a decade.
They're both involved in
the Jack Welch Management
Institute, which is a
leadership development
program and an online
MBA program as well.
And they're here to
speak to us today
about their book, "The
Real Life MBA: Your no
BS guide to winning the
game, building a team,
and growing your career."
And everything that
you talk about in here
resonates incredibly deeply.
It's a personal
thrill, actually,
to be here because of my
own history, my few minutes
I spent at GE, unfortunately
after your tenure.
And it's a delight to meet
you in person as well, Suzy.
So as you can see, I had a
lot of comments and questions.
So what we do is
I'd kick things off,
and then we'll open
it up to questions.
We also have an online page
where people online are
submitting questions,
and somebody
will come up and tee those up.
JACK WELCH: Great.
LASZLO BOCK: And I have
the advantage in that
I've read this cover to cover.
I don't know if everybody in the
room has yet had a chance to.
But just for a context
setting question,
it's been about 20 years
since you've been at GE,
and you two have been partners
in crime for some time.
What have you been up to?
What have you been doing?
JACK WELCH: Traveling the world,
selling a message of business.
Business is good.
Winning is good.
When companies win,
good things happen.
You get a cheerful crowd
like this in the room
because Google wins.
You wouldn't have that
if it was in the tank.
So basically we're out
selling how to make it win
and why winning is good.
And we're also running 24
private equity companies.
And we started a school,
which now has 900 MBAs.
We've spoken to over a
million and a quarter people.
Excuse my voice.
I've been doing this
for three weeks.
And I'm a burned out guy
now, but I love doing it.
We both love doing it,
and we learn every day
from different people.
We've been in the Midwest.
We've been across
the East Coast.
And then we've been in
this beautiful bubble
called California.
LASZLO BOCK: Now,
you were saying
when we were talking before
that what you see here
in Silicon Valley-- and you've
been to some other companies.
You've talked to folks.
You were both telling me
it's a little different from
once you get 50 miles from here,
once you get in the Midwest,
once you get to the South.
What are you seeing everywhere?
How's it different?
JACK WELCH: Well,
it's a tougher grind.
It's a tougher grind.
Since the 2008 recession, things
have gotten a lot tougher.
And people out there aren't
back to employment levels
they were at before.
They're not sure that the
company that they signed up for
is still the same company.
They've lost some benefits.
Some other things
have gone away.
Companies have shrunk down.
The word across most of the
country is do more with less.
That's the slogan.
No matter where you
go, do more with less.
It's not the slogan here.
SUZY WELCH: This
morning when we were
getting ready to come here--
we've been here for a few days,
and obviously we in
our lives had dealings
with Silicon Valley companies.
And I just was ruminating.
And I said to Jack, it is really
like a different planet here.
We've just been
through the Midwest,
Kansas City, Minneapolis.
And just the questions
are different,
and the expressions
are different.
And it's like this
very-- and I'm
saying this in the most
positive way, because it's
a beautiful thing.
But it's a very
shiny, happy place
compared to many other
pockets in the United States.
Where the sense of
possibility here is amazing,
but we've been in rooms
filled with people
who have a very different
sense of what the world feels
like right now.
And wouldn't it be an
amazing, marvelous thing
if the whole country
was experiencing
what you're experiencing?
It's great.
JACK WELCH: The best way to
think about this is Google
runs a survey every quarter.
SUZY WELCH: Not Google.
JACK WELCH: Not Google.
I mean Gallop runs
a-- I'm at Google,
so I got Google on the brain.
LASZLO BOCK: We do surveys
every quarter, too.
JACK WELCH: Gallop does
a survey every quarter
on employee
engagement in America.
And in the recession,
it got down to the point
where 70%, in 2008, of employees
didn't like going to work,
were not engaged in their job,
didn't like what was going on.
Today, six years later,
seven years later,
it's 65% in the
last quarter that
are disengaged with their work.
They don't like work.
Work isn't part of their life.
They don't see it as
part of their life.
It's a way to get a check.
And that's a terrible thing.
And so we're out
trying to change that.
We're out trying to get
people to have this feeling
of excitement, about growth.
Growth is an elixir.
And what you can do to grow,
how you can grow, how you get
aligned-- all these things.
We think-- and we've seen
it in private equity.
I've been involved with 74
companies over the last 15
years, 24 are active now.
And we've changed lives
at these companies,
because these companies were
orphans in big companies.
They were broken companies.
You don't buy a private equity
company because it's healthy.
You buy a sick company
and try and fix it.
And you spend several
years fixing it,
and then giving it freedom.
But that life is not going
on in many companies.
LASZLO BOCK: But you
started out by saying
you're about preaching winning.
And you famously are
known for-- at GE,
you said you have to be
number one or number two
in an industry,
or get out of it.
You talk about the importance
of growth, of winning.
What you write about here and
what you're hinting at now
is people just not
enjoying their work,
about there not being meaning.
And in the book, you
talk about the importance
of having a mission.
Is a mission the
same as winning?
Is winning sufficient?
Or is there something
bigger, better?
JACK WELCH:
Winning's the product
of a good mission, and
a good set of behaviors,
and the consequences
that come from it.
So winning is the result.
It's not a starting point.
Like, for example, we say
the chief characteristic
of a leader is to be a
chief meaning officer.
Give the work purpose.
People come to work because
they want a purpose.
They want to have
a reason for being.
They want to be a part of it.
And your job as a
leader is to let people
know why they're
there, where they're
going, why they're going there.
And then when
everybody leaves out
in most places, what's in
it for them to go there?
And what are the consequences,
pro and con, of doing it right?
LASZLO BOCK: But how do
you find that meaning
in the kind of places you've
been to over the last week?
SUZY WELCH: I'm just think
about these two anecdotes.
I hear your
question, and this is
a little bit of a roundabout
way of saying this.
For many years
after Jack retired,
we ran a seminar called
"Two Days with Jack Welch."
Where 100 CEOs would come
in from around the world,
and they would work
with Jack for two days.
And when we first did the
planning for this Jack said,
I'm just going to
spend the first hour
on just talking about mission.
Because all these
CEOs surely know
what the mission is
of their company,
and then we'll move
right on to X, Y, and Z.
So the first day starts out,
and Jack looks at this crowd--
100 CEOs who had self-selected
to come to a group
to work on management.
So you'd think they'd
be very self-actualized
and enlightened.
And I was sitting at one
table with a bunch of CEOs,
so I could hear what
they were saying.
And Jack said, OK, so just
jot down your mission.
And there was this weird,
uncomfortable silence.
And I was actually
sitting at a table
with two brothers who were
co-CEOs of a family company.
And one brother said to the
other, what's our mission?
And you're here.
We've been here.
We've been at Google an hour
and a half or something.
I've heard the mission
mentioned repeatedly.
We got a demo.
We met people in the hallway.
And the mission is just
flowing all out of you,
and I actually think you also--
LASZLO BOCK: Are you
getting sick of it by now?
SUZY WELCH: No, I
actually dig it a lot.
I was saying to Jack, too bad
none of our kids are engineers.
They know poetry and whatever.
Because this is
the kind of place
a mother would want
her kid to work.
And so because of that mission
and that sense of incredible--
I think you all know
what you're doing here
and how your work is
connected to the mission.
And secondly, in
our 10, 12 years
traveling around
the world, we've
made the point
over and over again
that it's imperative
for leaders, no matter
if you're a leader of 300
people or three people,
to make sure that your
people know where they stand.
How they're doing, what
they're doing well,
what they could be doing
better, what the trajectory
of their career looks like.
And when we travel around we
say to crowds, how many of you
know where you stand?
And it is a very, very good
day when 15% of the crowd
raises their hands.
We were in Chicago
the other day.
600 people we asked
this question.
Four people raised their
hands, knew where they stood.
It was a big business group.
And so they didn't know
the meaning of their work.
Clearly, if you're not having
a conversation about where
you stand and what you
could be doing better,
you don't even know what
the meaning of your work is.
This is why that number is
65% of people disengaged.
So you should all
pinch yourselves
because I bet you
know where you stand.
And we did this yesterday
at a Silicon Valley company,
and 85% of the hands went up.
JACK WELCH: No,
it was about 60%.
SUZY WELCH: But it
was still better
than any place we've been.
JACK WELCH: Any place we've
been Do you want to try it here?
LASZLO BOCK: Oh no, no, no.
I'm terrified.
Do not.
We can try it.
SUZY WELCH: Let's try it.
LASZLO BOCK: Let's do it.
JACK WELCH: How many people
here know what their boss thinks
of them, they know
exactly where they stand,
and what their
career trajectory is?
LASZLO BOCK: Come on.
Thank god.
SUZY WELCH: You win.
JACK WELCH: Well, I'd say 60%.
SUZY WELCH: No, no.
I think a little
bit higher, Jack.
Let's do it again.
LASZLO BOCK: Looks
like 110% to me.
It was not 100%.
There was like four
people in there.
Kevin, I'm looking at you.
SUZY WELCH: Taking names.
LASZLO BOCK: No,
but it's actually
something we're not
always great at,
because we love-- we focus
on hiring great people.
And then we try to give
them a lot of freedom.
And we try to get
managers great.
But it's a hard thing even
for us to get managers
to have those tough messages.
And later in the book,
you talk about this.
You have a section-- I'm going
to skip ahead-- where you talk
about a woman named Lauren.
Lauren is a financial analyst.
She's 34.
She'd heard whispers that she
might be made a partner as part
of a management transition.
And you go on.
But suddenly the
whispers stopped,
and Lauren was
informed by a colleague
that her boss was the reason.
And you continue on.
And eventually
Lauren was asked--
we asked Lauren--
you two asked Lauren
if her boss felt the same way
about her value to the firm
as she felt about her
value to the firm.
And she said, he
just doesn't want
me to be a partner
because I'm a woman.
He got pissed off when I went
to part time after my baby.
And you write,
was that the case?
It's possible.
But here's the story.
Lauren was guessing.
When we pressed
her, she admitted
she had no clue
how her boss really
felt about her performance
long before her baby
or after, because
he'd never told her.
And so that makes me wonder.
And it's great that we
actually weren't quite at 100%.
Whose job is it to make
sure the employee knows
where they stand?
Is it the boss's job?
Is it the employee's job?
Is it shared 50-50?
JACK WELCH: No, I think
it's without question
the boss's job, but the
employee has a responsibility,
if they've got a bad boss,
to press on about it.
And we talk about
career purgatories,
about working for
a boss that doesn't
have your interests at heart.
That happens in
every good company.
It'll happen.
You'll get a bad boss.
We talk about bosses that
don't have the generosity gene.
That aren't generous
about their praise,
generous about their rewards,
steal ideas and take them up
as their own-- all those things.
So you've got to put
timetables on those situations.
But it really is the boss's job.
We have a daughter.
You might tell this
story, this one story.
SUZY WELCH: So one of our
daughters works in LA.
And she's in the
entertainment business
where she was very
happy to get a job.
So she's working
away, and you can
imagine having your career
managed from afar by us, right?
So she actually
is working in LA,
and she doesn't know
how she's doing.
She's working very,
very hard, but her sense
of her performance rises and
falls on her boss's mood, OK?
So he's in a good mood,
she's doing great.
JACK WELCH: And we
get a phone call.
If the boss grunts,
we get a phone call.
SUZY WELCH: The phone
calls and the texts
are related to his mood.
So then one day, she
gets a raise in the mail,
in her paycheck.
And she calls us, and
she's ecstatic, second
only to us being ecstatic,
that she got a raise.
And she said, I got a raise.
I got a raise.
We said, well, why
did you get the raise?
And she doesn't
have any idea why.
So because she's related
to us, we said to her,
you have to go in and find
out why you got this raise.
No, no.
I don't want to piss him off.
We said, you've got to find
out why you got the raise.
So finally under
extreme pressure,
she went in, into his office.
We can only imagine it was
like, hi, sorry to bother you.
And so she said, I got a raise.
I'm really happy.
Can you tell me why?
And he looked at her,
and said to her, merit.
Period.
That's it.
JACK WELCH: And what
do you do with that?
SUZY WELCH: And she
ran out the door.
She was so happy to get
an answer and call us
and say, guess what?
I got a raise as a merit!
And she still doesn't
know what it was.
Now, since then,
she's been promoted.
So clearly they're happy
with her performance.
But right now all she knows
about what she does well
is "merit."
LASZLO BOCK: So
what's your advice
then to somebody who's got a
bad boss, who's not telling you
where you stand.
Just that you're
fine, you're fine.
Your bonus is kind of OK.
It's great.
Maybe it goes up a little
each year, whatever.
Do you confront the boss?
Do you push for an answer?
What's your advice?
JACK WELCH: No, I think
the way you go is,
I'd like to talk to you about
how you feel about my work.
How do you feel?
What do you think
I'm doing well?
And how do you
think I can improve?
How can I really improve?
Because I want to do
a better job here.
And you don't ever
confront them head on.
You go with what
can I do better?
LASZLO BOCK: Wait.
Why don't you
confront them head on?
Why don't you just say,
what's going on with me?
JACK WELCH: Well, you
can say, what's going on?
But you've got to ask
them, what can I do better?
Don't go in and start
challenging them.
It doesn't make sense.
It's suicide.
LASZLO BOCK: Yeah.
JACK WELCH: But come
at it the other way.
How can I do better?
And what do you think I
have to do to move on?
What do you think would
be the criteria that
would get me the next level?
LASZLO BOCK: Yeah.
Well, the two of you, you
talk about later in the book
when you're into
the personal advice.
You have a section called
"Why Careers Stall,"
which is related to this.
Because often your career
stalls, probably you also often
aren't getting feedback.
And you're trying
to figure it out.
And you talk about careers
stalling for a few reasons.
You've got a blocker above you.
You can't grow.
You talk about how
to resolve that.
You talk about
wrongheaded notions
about the importance of
multifunctional expertise.
You talk about boss haters,
and you talk about purgatory.
It's like Dante's "Inferno"
of career management here.
It's awful.
So can you talk a little bit
about-- if you feel stuck,
what is a blocker?
What does that look like-- ahead
of you, above you, around you?
And how we can step
through each of these.
JACK WELCH: A
blocker is somebody
who's enjoying your great work,
and is very happy to keep you
in the draw to keep
getting all that good work,
so that they look very good.
That could be one
case of a blocker.
Another case of blocker is--
and these Midwestern companies
we were talking about
is-- there's no growth.
The boss is going nowhere.
That doesn't happen here.
There's plenty of growth
creating opportunities
all the time.
But in many companies,
most of the world right now
with a GDP of 0.8%
growth doesn't
have all these jobs opening up.
So you're stuck there
in a no-growth situation
with a good boss maybe.
But what you have to do
in all these situations
is control your own destiny.
You've got to put
a timeframe on it.
I'll stick it out here for
two years, or one year,
whatever you decide.
Pick a time frame
and I'll overdeliver.
I'll give them more than
they have ever seen before.
And if nothing happens, I've got
to take my wares and move on.
LASZLO BOCK: Why do you
think-- when you say it,
that's fantastic advice.
Most people don't do that.
Why not?
JACK WELCH: Insecurity,
lack of self-confidence,
comfortable where they are.
Or maybe family situations--
kids, can't move,
they're in high school,
college, whatever.
SUZY WELCH: Momentum,
inertia, humanity,
and the fear of the unknown.
And I think also
sometimes people
don't do anything
because they have
this little nagging voice inside
saying maybe the problem is me.
And it's just much easier not
to look at that piece of it,
and so they'd rather
just bump along.
JACK WELCH: I used
to go to Crotonville,
which is our education place.
And I would teach every class.
And I would spend three
hours in the class Q&A.
And then I'd spent
three hours at the bar,
and I'd learn more
at the bar than I
did in the teaching program.
But basically what I
would always leave them
with-- always-- love being
here, love being at GE,
but be ready to leave.
So that put the pressure
on the leadership.
If the leadership wasn't
taking care of you,
and we started seeing
good people leaving
in a certain area-- and it
didn't happen very often
in those days.
It didn't happen very often.
But if it did, we knew
we had a bad boss.
Just like if you have
a plant, a factory--
we had a lot of factories.
And when a union showed up,
and a union took a vote,
and they got a
positive vote-- now,
we never formed a union in
the 21 years I was there.
But whenever it
came up for a vote,
we knew we had a
jackass plant manager.
Because otherwise it
wouldn't get there.
If you had the right
atmosphere, the right feelings
in the place, a transparency--
we want transparency.
Transparency is
the biggest virtue
you can have in a company.
And if you have a
transparent spot,
you won't have unions forming.
People will think they
have voice anyway.
They will have voice.
They only form a
union to get voice,
because nobody's
listening otherwise.
LASZLO BOCK: So when you
have these situations--
and I want to circle
back to the career side,
but you've both seen
a ton of companies.
And every time in the book
you talk about a leadership
transition, you talk
about firing people.
And this isn't the stack
rank 70/20/10 stuff.
You talk about Eric
Fyrwald at Nalco.
And he goes in, and he moved on.
You say many top
leaders had to be
asked to move on-- more
than half of the top 100
So new CEO, 50% or more
of the people gone.
And then you say a
personnel move speaks louder
than 100 speeches.
And there's a few other
parts of the book where
you talk about the
importance of when
you come in as a leader firing
some of the people under you.
Is that just good hygiene?
JACK WELCH: We're talking
there about private equity.
LASZLO BOCK: OK.
JACK WELCH: So in
private equity,
the reason why you
buy a company is
it's an orphan,
usually, in a company.
It's a division
that isn't liked.
I'm not sure at Google there are
some, but I'll bet there are.
A division that's
the turkey over here.
It gets less attention
from the top people.
It doesn't get loved.
It doesn't get enough
resources compared to others.
There are those
in most companies.
So you buy these companies
because the company
wants to trim down, particularly
with activists out there now.
Companies are selling
off divisions,
and you grab a division.
Well, those people haven't
been looked at for 10 years.
They've been sitting
over there, not growing,
not performing, but not
being told anything.
So you bring them in, and
you've got to get a fresh eye,
look at the situation.
So we're talking
mainly about companies
you're acquiring that have been
dead on their feet for years.
SUZY WELCH: And I
think a lot of times,
and especially in
those stories, when
you want your company to
be productive, and fast,
and creative, and innovative,
and all those things,
people pretty much need
to share the values.
And the values have to
be things like teamwork,
and like maybe you have
here, fast failure.
You have values that you
want people to demonstrate.
And so when there are these
leadership transitions,
if a leader comes in
and says, you know what?
I am installing these values,
the values of urgency,
and speed, and boundarylessness.
And you have people
who-- there's
a great story in
the book, I think,
when Dave Calhoun
came into Nielsen.
And he knew that this
was a silo company where
nobody spoke to each other.
And he knew that if it was
going to survive and be
the company he
wanted it to be, he
needed people who
wanted to share ideas.
And he tried and tried
to get that value across.
But when he found managers that
just would not share ideas,
he had to ask them to move on.
So it's a lot about values.
You guys talk
about values a lot,
so this should sound
pretty familiar, right?
LASZLO BOCK: Imagine a
company that's going great,
and you have a leadership
change at whatever level, right?
Doesn't have to be CEO.
Could be division,
what have you.
What are the odds
that they're not
going to have to fire anybody
from the direct reports?
JACK WELCH: We bought
two medical companies
in high growth industries
that were underfunded,
and we didn't touch a person.
And we've had 6x returns
with just pouring money
at them, giving them
the resources to grow.
They were flourishing.
Now, you rarely find
those birds, OK?
Whenever you find a
blue bird like that,
you go home and
rub, rub your hands.
Life is easy.
It's all good.
And you take it public, and
in two years and make 6x.
LASZLO BOCK: And you
look like a genius.
JACK WELCH: An absolute genius.
All you did was give
good people money.
LASZLO BOCK: That's
a good strategy.
SUZY WELCH: Yeah.
JACK WELCH: The thing you
have in your book, which
I like so much, and I've
never seen it written out.
I write it all the
time, but I've never
seen, other than
you and I, this idea
of paying great people lots.
Paying great people.
We have a story in
here of getting whacked
and recovering from a whack.
And what we talk about
there is the 2008 Recession.
We were so brilliant.
We bought this company
called Home Depot Supply.
And Home Depot Supply
sold lots of goods
to the construction industry.
In 2007, it was booming.
Housing booming,
everything booming.
And it was doing $12
billion in revenues.
In 2008, four quarters later,
it was doing $7 billion.
It collapsed on itself.
And so our smart
decision to buy it
couldn't have been worst timing.
Could not have
been worse timing.
We get it, and this guy Joe
D'Angelo brings his team.
He'd been hiring
them for sometime,
a bunch of people he
worked with before.
His first act was not let's
cut 10% across the board.
We've got to save money.
No, his first thing was pay
the aces tons of equity,
tons of equity.
I've got to keep the stars.
If I'm going to get out of
this whack, where he's probably
going bankrupt, the first
thing I've got to do
is make the stars know we're
all swimming in the same tank
together.
And I'm giving
you lots of money.
Well, to make that
a long story short,
he did lots of other things
to get out of that whack.
And we talk about
getting out of a whack.
We'll all have whacks
business-wise, personal,
you'll get hit, and
how you get out of it.
Well, this is a
story of this guy
taking the absolute
non-traditional way
of doing it.
He went at give me
the aces in the game,
and I'll give them
all the money.
Well, they just went public
about six months ago.
The top team-- now,
this isn't big money
by Silicon Valley
standards, but the top guys
got over $100 million.
LASZLO BOCK: That's
big money even here.
JACK WELCH: Even here?
LASZLO BOCK: Let me
correct you, yeah.
That counts.
JACK WELCH: No, and
the mid-level guys all
got $20 to $40 million.
LASZLO BOCK: That's
also big money.
JACK WELCH: But it was fabulous.
But they hung in there
through six years
of fighting that mess.
But he did the opposite of
what you traditionally see.
Nothing's worse than
anything across the board--
across the board raises,
across the board cuts--
they're all sinful
things to do in business.
They're just cowards.
LASZLO BOCK: Well, we were
talking about this a little
beforehand.
So you find your aces.
You give them the big equity.
The middle people,
they kind of get it.
They're worker bees.
The people at the bottom--
JACK WELCH: But they
get some equity.
LASZLO BOCK: OK,
they get equity, too.
What do you do
about the layer just
below the ones who
get the giant awards?
JACK WELCH: That's the
toughest layer to manage.
I We started out with a
system, Bill Conaty and I,
of going 10, 15, 50, 15, 10.
LASZLO BOCK: And Bill
Conaty was your head of--
JACK WELCH: Head of HR.
And we were partners in this.
We [? lived ?] people
the whole time.
That was our whole job in GE.
We didn't spend a lot
of time on other stuff.
And the trouble
always came in trying
to make these
careful slices of 10
between the top 10
and the next 15.
We're all humans.
We're making these
cuts, and we're not
really that good at making them,
so we piss off the next group.
So we cut that down to top
20, middle 70, bottom 10
to try and get a distribution
that looked like this.
And the biggest
problem you have is
taking good people in the
middle and telling them
they're in the middle.
That by far is the hardest job.
And so I always erred on pushing
them to the top of the middle
and getting them as close
as you could to the top.
LASZLO BOCK: And
they're happy with that?
They live happily ever
after, or they were just
slightly less unhappy?
JACK WELCH: You've got to
understand that these ratings
are a period in time.
They're not a lifetime sentence.
I'm in the top 5%.
Am I there forever?
No, if you stink,
you'd get out of there.
And if you're in the
next group, you guys
have 5, 20, or whatever.
You've got that five tier thing.
And people that can move by
performance-- the thing we've
got to get clear though
on performance-- even you
in your letter had a
little misunderstanding
of what our thing was.
When you're looking at
valuing where people are,
there are two axes.
On one axis is behaviors, the
values of the company-- speed,
boundaryless
behavior, et cetera.
Now, you do that, a separate
evaluation of these things.
And you put a half
circle or a full circle,
because you can't put a
numerical number to those.
You fill in a circle.
If they're fully
qualified in that area,
they get a full circle,
half circle, quarter circle,
whatever.
And then you come
up with a judgment.
This is how this employee
adheres to the behaviors
we need to win.
Because it's where we're going.
That's the mission.
How we're going to get there,
or the behaviors, and then
the consequences.
And then on the
bottom axis you've
got numerical performance.
Whether it's sales quotas,
R&D, new products--
whatever you pick as the
financial measurements.
Then you draw four
quadrants of people.
And it's low to high
on each axis, OK?
Low to high-- I wish we had
a little whiteboard here--
but low to high.
In the top right, you've got
high values, high behaviors,
and high performance.
That's easy, onward and upward.
On the bottom left
quadrant, you've
got low behaviors
and low numbers.
That's easy, too.
Give them some time to either
fix it, or they move on.
Then the third type over
here on the upper left.
You've got low performance but
high behaviors-- very good.
They're on your team.
They believe in
everything you believe in.
You give them a second,
third, fourth chance.
Because when you
get somebody who
buys into the whole system,
the mission, if you will,
the mission of Google, the
mission of company X, Y, or Z.
You want that person.
But it's the fourth
quadrant out to the right
that kills companies.
And I'm sure you've
seen them here,
and you've see them everywhere.
The high performer
who's a horse's ass.
And every time you
tolerate that person--
and you talk about your
values and behaviors.
And you've got some jerk who's
kissing up and kicking down
while getting good numbers,
you keep tolerating him.
And you give speeches on
values, and mission, and beauty,
and peace, and everything else.
But you've got this person.
Every promotion of
that person, every time
that person gets promoted, you
ruin 50 speeches, 500 speeches.
Stop flapping your lips.
Don't talk about it.
So that person with
high performing numbers
and lousy values is
a killer of culture.
It's a killer of culture.
LASZLO BOCK: You
talk about, I think,
this is a category of that.
You talk about boss haters.
Like when you talk about
why careers get stalled,
to come back to that, some of
it is you've got a blocker.
The other category was
you've spread too wide,
which if we have time,
we'll come back to.
But talking about low values,
you talk about boss haters,
and how they don't know
they're boss haters,
or they don't admit it.
But they're toxic,
they're poisonous.
JACK WELCH: I'm
going to come back
to that, because I want to stay
in this other thing a minute
more.
LASZLO BOCK: Please.
JACK WELCH: Because
you talked about,
it in your book, Microsoft,
and you talked about Yahoo.
And you talked about rank
and yank, that terrible word.
It was destroying
those companies.
You talked to, you
interviewed people, et cetera.
That facts are you couldn't
be in the top performing group
if you didn't have teamwork.
Because you're in
the wrong place.
They're looking at numbers.
Enron was all numbers, OK?
That's a misapplication
of a theory of the case.
You're an important guy to
carry this message long term.
That's why I'm pitching you.
No, it's very real.
You can't be a bad team player
or a bad behaving person
and be in the top 10.
LASZLO BOCK: So
let's dig into that.
So I agree, but let's
explore for the folks who
are watching and listening.
So somebody who has great
numbers, great salespeople,
brilliant engineer,
total jerk, horse's ass.
You can see that.
What about the people where
they're not at both extremes?
Great numbers, but
they're a jerk sometimes.
They kick down sometimes.
They're kind of political.
Where do you draw the line?
Where would you call?
How much of that kind of
behavior is acceptable?
Is any of it, or is none of it?
JACK WELCH: You can
tell-- do people
want to hang out with them?
Do they have a place
where people want to work?
Are they attracting people?
Or are people dodging them?
LASZLO BOCK: Well, that's
one thing we've seen here.
Because we do surveys.
We love our data.
We do surveys about what do
you think of your manager
every six months?
And one of things
that happens is
we see people who are
kind of brutal, really
rough, tough managers.
And what ends up happening
is the teams end up
giving them positive scores.
Because they say,
well, you know what?
I don't like working
for this person,
but I know where I stand.
Or you know what?
I've learned more than
I've ever learned.
Yeah, I get beat
up once in awhile,
but I'm learning so much
because this person's direct
and in my face.
And what's interesting is
when those people move jobs,
the leaders move jobs,
no one follows them.
And the team kind of
goes-- [SIGH OF RELIEF]
But every measurement
we have along the way,
you look at it objectively.
And people go like, oh yeah.
You know, it's fine.
I can deal with it.
Is this like having a bad
boyfriend or girlfriend?
You just can't break up?
What's the secret?
JACK WELCH: No, you're
going to have some--
LASZLO BOCK: And how do
you find those people?
JACK WELCH: Look,
you're going to look
till the last day you
breathe, and you're not
going to get them all.
You can get faked out
on this all the time.
Nobody has a perfect system.
The question is what's
a better system?
It's always going to be that.
Because you can always
argue against the perfect,
but no system is perfect.
But you've got to be
able to evaluate people
on two axes, not one.
And now you may
not get it right.
You may not be
perfect, but you'll
be better than any
other system out there.
LASZLO BOCK: I think you're
right about the second axis.
I think we need that.
We absolutely do.
I have one question I
want to say for the end,
but I want to open
it up for questions
either that are
submitted online,
or if anyone in the
room has questions.
Actually, I have a whole bunch
of questions, but if anyone
wants to start migrating.
Do you want to just
run to the mic,
so we can get a
recording of that?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks again for
coming to Google.
One of the challenges
that any large company has
is remote office workers
in developing their talent.
What are some the best
strategies you've seen?
I know you developed talent
in your remote offices
when you were at GE.
What are some of
the best strategies
you've seen for owning your
own career as a remote office
worker?
JACK WELCH: Well, I'll try
a couple, and you try some.
We have an online
school, all remote.
And the biggest
challenge is how do you
socialize that office to believe
they belong to the mothership?
It's a huge deal.
You've got to make
all kinds of efforts.
What we do is we have pivot
points on the computer screen.
We know how many
contacts the dean
has with every faculty
member per week.
We know how many
contacts every dean has,
every faculty member
has with every student.
An online school is the
toughest thing in the world.
People are working all day, go
home and do the work at night.
They got a sick kid.
The worst thing can
happen and they'll
have to stay up all
night and do a paper,
turn it in, get back, nice job.
Killer.
So they've got to
have that strength.
So we monitor totally
the socialization aspects
of faculty with the student,
the dean with the faculty.
We've got to bring them in.
And we talk about
subcontractors-- same thing.
Subcontractor has seven clients.
How do I make the
subcontractor like me
more so I get his
heart and soul?
Well, here, you feed him.
You do all kinds
of things, but you
want to get that subcontractor
with more allegiance to you
than to the other
six clients he has.
So you're always working
on socialization.
You're always bringing him into
the core as much as you can.
You're measuring how
many contacts you have.
You're doing all these
things to be sure that nobody
feels they're out on an island.
SUZY WELCH: I think
the main thing
is that if you don't actively
manage people who are working
remotely or virtually, if
you don't actively manage it
and you let it manage
itself, it falls apart.
And so managers often can feel--
I felt that way myself when
I was the editor of a magazine.
I had a lot of people
not working in the office
because editing can
be done anywhere.
And so a lot of people
were in life stages
where they wanted and
needed to work at home.
I worked with a lot of moms.
And you want to
accommodate them,
because they were so talented.
And you're so busy with
what you're doing day to day
that you just let it go.
And then you realize
six months have gone by
and you haven't
seen this person,
really talked to them.
Every interaction you've had
with them has been electronic.
It was easy, and it was
working pretty well.
And then you get that person
in, and you have a conversation.
And you think how much
better it could've been.
So I think you just have to
have it on your to-do list
to actively manage
remote relationships.
And if you just
let them go, which
is the natural
human thing to do,
you just are not getting
everything you can out of it,
and teamwork suffers.
JACK WELCH: The one
thing that Google
could bring to the
world, if you will,
is the ability to
socialize online education.
No matter how hard we try,
whether it be Blackboard,
whether it be this system
or the other system,
we still are missing
the socialization link
in our MBA program.
That's the weak
link in the system.
How do we get our students
more engaged in our game?
SUZY WELCH: And new technology
comes out all the time.
Believe me, we've seen it.
JACK WELCH: It's not enough.
SUZY WELCH: There's
nothing there yet.
JACK WELCH: We
need breakthroughs.
SUZY WELCH: Please do it!
JACK WELCH: Please do it!
And it would apply
to these offices.
LASZLO BOCK: Are you Google
for Education customers?
Because we can introduce
you to someone.
JACK WELCH: We looked at
Noodle and stuff like that.
We've looked at it.
It isn't good enough.
SUZY WELCH: Oh, oh.
JACK WELCH: It isn't!
No, it's a nice product,
but it isn't good enough.
SUZY WELCH: Next frontier.
LASZLO BOCK: OK.
Next question?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So I had a question on
your career management.
So there are two
approaches, right?
One is you stay
within a company,
and you grow, stay 20, 25
years within GE, or a company
like that.
And in the Silicon Valley,
it's more like every few years
you get a promotion, as in
joining another company,
and move around every few years.
So how would you contrast
the two approaches
to managing your career?
JACK WELCH: I don't think
you manage your career.
I think you manage your job.
And what you do is you
overdeliver all the time,
so you become a
commodity with gold stars
everywhere so
everybody wants you.
Anybody who's
managing their career,
picking, I'll go here next,
and I'll go here next.
And if I get that job,
then I'll get that job.
Killer performer.
Keep your eye on your job.
Do better than anybody's
ever done on that job,
and good things
will happen to you
is my view of all those
things, whether you
stay in that company or
go to another company.
LASZLO BOCK: That's actually
in your career chapter.
That's your first main point.
You say don't
deliver, overdeliver.
JACK WELCH: Yeah.
LASZLO BOCK: And again,
that's something most people
actually-- we do our best.
But most of us
don't think about it
as I'm going to kick
butt every single day.
I'm going to exceed
everyone's expectations.
SUZY WELCH: I think it's hard
to talk about that in this room.
Because I'm going to
presume that most of you
have been overdelivering since
you were in kindergarten.
LASZLO BOCK: Most of them.
Most of them.
SUZY WELCH: OK,
but overdelivering
is an interesting concept.
For some people, it's
very natural, OK?
But for others, it's not.
By overdelivering it
means doing-- in school,
you're taught to deliver.
Even when you're at a fine
school, you get the assignment.
You hand in the assignment.
You do the assignment very well.
And you're going to
get a great grade.
But when you get into the real
world, it's a different thing.
It's about making the
assignment much bigger.
You're asked to do
X. And you actually
give serious thought
to what more, what
would be the bigger question.
And so you deliver on X
and the bigger question.
Jack tells a great
story about when he was
trying to get out of the pile.
Early on he was a
chemical engineer PhD.
And his boss asked
him to present
to his boss about some plastic.
And instead, he presented to the
boss about the entire picture
of the plastics industry
in 5 and 10 years,
and did this McKinsey-like
presentation.
They couldn't believe it.
But that's overdelivering.
And so the question is, are
you thinking expansively
enough about your work?
And that is the way to
manage your careers,
if you are constantly
overdelivering.
And you've got to have
a certain natural love
and joy above the
work to be doing that,
and a certain natural engagement
and curiosity about the work
to be doing it.
Otherwise, it's
really hard labor.
JACK WELCH: One thing
to think about--
and this is a simple little tip.
Is your boss a lot smarter after
the meeting you had with him
or her than before the
meeting took place?
Is your boss going out and
can go to a cocktail party
and can blow smoke
about something
you gave him beautiful
insights into, or gave
her insights into?
Can he just end up smarter?
Did the boss just sit through
a mind-numbing, boring regime
of you telling him what you've
done, and how you're doing?
Or have you given him
an expansive, broad view
of the subject
that he asked about
or the meeting was
supposed to be about?
Think about that every time.
Never go to a meeting
without making
the boss you're dealing
with smarter for having sat
through that meeting with you.
Simple tip, but think about it.
LASZLO BOCK: But what
I love-- and then we'll
go to the question--
is that you keep
coming back to things that
I, as an individual, control.
I control how much
work I'm putting in.
I control whether I'm
going above and beyond.
I control what happens in
that meeting with the boss.
I control do I ask about--
the woman who asks,
what's my rating?
What's going on?
There's a huge focus on that.
And that's very different
from the typical advice, which
is, well, chart your course,
and check these boxes,
and get this experience.
JACK WELCH: I hate it.
Why would you?
We have an example in the book.
Everyone says, oh, get a lot
of multifunctional experience.
That'll do a lot for you.
I always say, don't bring
skates to the basketball court.
That's for hockey.
Don't try skating on
the basketball court.
Michael Jordan tried
playing baseball.
He stunk at it.
OK?
He went into pro baseball.
And do what you're good at and
just excel like hell at it,
and the sky's the limit.
LASZLO BOCK: That's how
a chemist becomes a CEO?
JACK WELCH: Yeah.
LASZLO BOCK: Yeah.
How good a chemist were you?
SUZY WELCH: A very good chemist.
JACK WELCH: Pretty average
bear, chemical engineer.
LASZLO BOCK: Yeah.
JACK WELCH: Pretty average bear.
LASZLO BOCK: Really?
JACK WELCH: Compared
to other PhDs.
But let me tell
you the difference.
I got a PhD with a
Nobel Prize winner.
I got out in three years.
Most of my peers took seven.
They were all
smarter than I was.
But they doddled.
They played in the lab.
They liked lab hours.
I wanted to get the
hell out of there.
SUZY WELCH: He wanted
to be with people.
JACK WELCH: I wanted
LASZLO BOCK: Yeah.
JACK WELCH: So I wasn't smarter
by any means, not even close.
But I was in a hurry.
LASZLO BOCK: I think
that might have
made-- I think we could
debate the smarter part.
I think you probably
did all right.
JACK WELCH: I did all right.
LASZLO BOCK: We'll see.
We'll see, I guess,
in the next few years
how things work out
for you, Jack Welch.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I was wondering if I could
ask a question about smaller
companies.
Because I think we
have a lot in common
here with small companies.
I was just curious if you,
having your experience at GE,
a big corporation, if there
are any-- because I think
small companies are often proud
of the fact that they're small,
and they don't have much in
common with corporations.
What do you think smaller
companies could incorporate--
practices, learnings--
from a big company
that you think
they often overlook
or avoid intentionally?
JACK WELCH: Well,
what a company always
wants to be-- don't forget that
plastic story we started with.
I was the first employee,
and 18 years later, we're
a $16 billion company.
We had one technician.
I hired the first one, the
second one, the third one.
Now, we had the luxury of
building that $16 billion
company in a big corporation
that didn't know anything
about plastics.
So we were shielded, and
we had lots of money.
We had a bank behind us.
So we weren't out starting
it up from the ground.
But what does a small
company never want to be?
It never wants to
be a bureaucracy.
What does a big
company want to be?
It wants to get rid of layers.
It wants to de-layer and
become a small company.
But what does a small
company want to be?
It wants to have leverage
in the marketplace.
So it has to have unique
products to get leverage
in the marketplace.
It must be unique.
It can't have just coverage.
So you want the muscle
of a big company
and the heart of
a small company.
And all these things
don't go together.
For example, when you talk
about business as a sport,
the team with the
best players wins.
That's what I happens in sports.
The team with the best
players playing together wins.
That's what happens in business.
So it doesn't matter
whether you're
a small business
or a big business,
you want the best players.
You want to constantly
reward the best.
You want to do all the same
things, but you don't want--
I was talking at LinkedIn
yesterday and talking here
today.
You guys are now a bureaucracy.
You can have all the food and
all the stuff around here,
but you're a bureaucracy.
Come on.
You got guys like him with
forms and all that stuff.
It happens.
LASZLO BOCK: I'm going to
survey them about this talk
afterwards.
I want the forms.
SUZY WELCH: You have
to fear and loathe--
JACK WELCH: You're
fighting every day,
but you've got layers.
You're adding layers.
You can't have this many
people and not have layers.
But you've got to fight.
Every layer has to go through
the scrutiny of-- you've
got to start from
the standpoint of I
never want to have a layer.
When you're starting a small
company, give them a salary.
You don't have to
give them a title.
Give them a salary.
Give them more span.
I had 29 direct reports.
Ideally, I should
have had 60 probably.
Because if you don't have
a lot of draft reports,
you can't meddle.
And if you're good
people, you want
them to have their own heads.
So you've got to fight
like hell all the time
not to layer up a place.
Every layer is evil.
It spins messages.
It delays decision making.
It does all these
terrible things.
LASZLO BOCK: So on this
point, one of things you
talk about, one of these--
JACK WELCH: I probably
didn't answer your question,
but you understand the theory.
LASZLO BOCK: One
of the things you
talk about in terms
of bureaucracy
is you touch very
briefly on budgets.
And you talk about how every
company has these budget
negotiations internally about
how much you're going to spend.
And you write-- there's
this beautiful line about,
and somehow, you always end
up in the middle, right?
Because people-- how do
you cut through that?
How do you get
people to be honest?
JACK WELCH: Look, the
main point in this book
is what a leader's job is.
It's to create an atmosphere
of truth and trust,
where every meeting-- you can
have a neon light up here--
there's only truth
being spun here.
No spin, no BS.
We want the truth only.
Because everybody
comes in with a pitch,
and they have their own biases.
They're pitching
it, spinning it.
Let's take the bunch of
review as a perfect example.
I'm in the field.
I come in to headquarters at
Google here with my budget.
And I'll come in and
say the market stinks.
The world's coming to an end.
The Chinese are killing us.
This is happening here.
All I can do is two.
And then the bosses here
will say, I need four.
And you go into
a windowless room
and sit there and bang heads.
There'll be no customers,
no analysts, nobody around.
And you'll sit there for seven
hours with presentations,
and slides, and all that stuff.
And you'll come out with three.
That's the budget for the year.
Nothing will have happened.
The only measurements
that count is
how did you do
against last year,
and how did you do against
any competitors you
measure against?
That's all that counts.
Measuring against a budget
is the dumbest thing
that was ever invented in
business-- the dumbest thing.
Because a budget
is a negotiation
between two human beings.
It has nothing to
do with the world.
It's crazy.
It's stupid.
LASZLO BOCK: Yeah, you about
looking at variance instead,
right?
You talk about variance instead?
JACK WELCH: Everything's
variance in my mind.
We have a chapter in here--
"Don't be Afraid of Finance."
If you understand
variance analysis,
how does the marketing
budget compare to last year?
And are the sales
going up because you
doubled the marketing
budget, or are they not?
Everything against a
variance, against last year,
against two years ago.
And you're acquiring
a company, why
are you going to spend that much
versus what they spent before?
Everything's variance.
It's arithmetic.
Is not DCRRs, or DSDCFs,
or IRRs, and all that crap.
You don't need it.
You need to understand variance.
That's what you need in finance.
LASZLO BOCK: I don't know
if Cliff's still here
who has the Dory questions,
but if there's one--
AUDIENCE: We got them all.
LASZLO BOCK: Oh,
we got them all?
OK.
And if there's any
other questions,
we've got a few minutes left.
Two last things, one
super-- well, actually,
in all your travels, what's the
biggest business opportunity
out there?
What's the biggest, most
exciting thing on the horizon?
And not at a high level, like
online learning, or digital,
or something like that.
But if you were starting out,
what industry would you go in?
What problem would you tackle?
What would you do?
JACK WELCH: You want a go?
SUZY WELCH: I think
that's one for you.
I can do one thing.
I can write.
So for me, it's like the world
doesn't need that many more
writers.
JACK WELCH: Well,
I think biotech
is just the most exciting
area in the world right now.
LASZLO BOCK: Why's that?
JACK WELCH: Because
you're dealing
with a clear-cut mission.
You've got one mission.
It's easy.
Now, we have a medical
system business in GE.
We buy medical companies.
It's not a problem getting
the mission understood
by everybody.
You're changing lives.
You're making lives better.
You're doing all that.
I think it's a frontier now
with enormous upside to explore.
LASZLO BOCK: But
people have said this
about biotech, like 10
years ago, 20 years ago.
Is it different
today than it was?
JACK WELCH: Yes,
it's much hotter now.
There's much more breakthroughs.
Drugs are coming out much
faster through technology.
LASZLO BOCK: Yeah.
What about-- well,
actually, do you want to?
JACK WELCH: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
I'm in a position where I'm
choosing a new team right now.
What are some of the
things that I should be
looking for in my new manager?
What should I look
for in a boss?
JACK WELCH: You are
choosing to go to a team?
SUZY WELCH: No, you're
building a team?
AUDIENCE: No, I'm
moving to a new team.
SUZY WELCH: OK, so what are
you looking for in your boss?
JACK WELCH: Go through it.
SUZY WELCH: Your
generosity theme?
JACK WELCH: Yeah.
SUZY WELCH: So there's
one characteristic
that we think separates a
good boss from a great boss.
And that's this thing that
we call the generosity gene.
It's technically not a
gene, but it is a-- OK,
I have to say that.
LASZLO BOCK: Hold your
questions on that.
She knows it's not a gene.
SUZY WELCH: And I only
say that because Jack
calls it the generosity gene,
and I'm always there piping up,
saying all right.
And maybe it is, what do I know?
But I think what it
is, and you've seen it,
and you've all experienced it.
It's this preponderance, this
desire, this burning desire
in an individual to see
the people working for him
or her growing.
And they get really psyched
about giving promotions,
and raises, and seeing
people get things right,
and just getting better.
We've all worked for bosses
with the generosity gene who
have this incredible
heart of love, really,
for people to grow, and to get
better, and really love you
as an individual, and
see you get more money,
and see you get promoted, and
see you even leave the team
to go on to bigger
and better things.
And then we've all had the
bosses who steal your idea
and use it as their
own, and really
get stingy around
raises, and really get
stingy about celebrating you.
And so if you're
looking for what team
you're going to go to-- because
you'll go the extra mile.
And the team will be
that much more energized
when the leader has got
this generosity gene.
JACK WELCH: And if you think
about it-- stay there a minute.
If you think about
it, if you think
about it in this
room, all of you,
you've worked for both types.
You've worked for people
with a generous spirit.
that didn't have it.
Where was it more fun?
Where was it more enjoyable?
Because when I look
at the people that
have led in our company, in
the companies I've worked with,
74 private equity
companies and GE.
If I look at these guys, the
winning people, male or female,
they had this experience.
They loved to see
their people grow.
The biggest thrill
for me is we've
got-- you can count
them-- 50, 60,
70 CEOs out there
now who work for me.
Many of them-- you refer to
one in your book, Dave Cote.
They were all chief
executives of GE businesses.
That's the biggest
turn-on in the world
to have the Boeing CEO, the
Honeywell CEO, the Home Depot
CEO.
All these people
were my partners.
They're my friends.
And the nice thing--
Google's got to have that.
They probably have a
lot of it now already,
whether it be Marissa Meyer,
or whoever else is out there.
You'll have the same
raft because you've
got a human resource
process that works.
And that's one of the
great thrills of life
to see these people sprouting up
all over the place from Google.
And Google will be the
GE of the last 20 years,
20 years ago, going forward.
They'll have tons of CEOs
out there running companies.
And it'll be the biggest
turn-on for Google.
LASZLO BOCK: It is.
It is.
It's amazing to watch, folks.
So last question
for each of you.
JACK WELCH: Thanks
for that question.
LASZLO BOCK: You write in one
of the concluding chapters.
You say, to quote
from Mark Twain,
"the two most important
days in your life
are the day you were born and
the day you figure out why."
I'd love, if you don't
mind, for you to share
why were you each born?
Why are you here?
SUZY WELCH: I happen to
be a devout Christian.
So for me the
answer is just going
to be I was born to glorify God.
So I think that's a
really personal thing,
and probably if there's any
other Christians in the room,
they would have the same answer.
So that would be the answer.
Now, how I glorify God is I
have a gift, which is writing.
And I discovered that I had
that gift, like many writers do,
when I was really young.
I started a diary when
I was nine years old.
And I wrote in it
every single day.
And if I didn't write in
it, I felt like something
was really wrong.
So I was really lucky to
be able to have that gift.
And then I've been
unbelievably blessed
to find many different
ways to use that gift
to change people's lives.
And in fact, when
I was running HBR
when I would try
to recruit people,
I would say please come join
me help change the world.
That was just incredible.
So I was able to use my gift.
And all writers use their
gifts in different ways.
LAZLO BOCK: That's amazing.
Thank you.
JACK WELCH: No, I just
happened to be lucky.
Luck plays an enormous part in
where you get to in these jobs.
You bust your butt.
You do all these things.
But I love people.
And when I took this job
on, from the first plastic,
I loved my first employee,
to my second employee,
to my third employee.
I like hanging out.
And I like being with people.
And contrary to
what Laszlo feels--
and he's smarter and
brighter in some ways.
SUZY WELCH: Going for you.
JACK WELCH: No, I
believe in my gut.
I'm a gut guy.
I'm not an analyst.
I have a PhD and all that stuff,
but I believe in gut, and feel,
and touch, and people.
And I'll hire, and I'll
make mistakes with my gut
many times.
But so far, people like me.
They work hard for me.
We all work as a team.
It isn't me.
But I always hire people
smarter than me in every job
I've ever been in.
And I like them.
I like hang around with them.
If you like people,
it's a fun job.
It's a great job.
And that's what I like,
and so it all worked out.
I was captain of sports
all through college.
I was captain of
sports in high school.
People tend to
let me be captain.
So it seemed to be fun, and
I've never stopped liking it.
That's why we keep doing this.
We love these interchanges.
We learn everywhere we go.
We see these magnificent
people doing things.
And it's wonderful
to be out here where
you're seeing all this growth.
Because growth really
is an elixir of life.
It truly is.
It gives you a whole
new jolt. And we're
lucky enough and
fortunate enough
to have people come
and listen to us.
So thanks for being here.
LAZLO BOCK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And if I can just say two
quick things in closing.
One is it's not often you have
a discussion about a business
book that then hinges on
talk about God, and love,
and changing the world,
and transformation.
So it's an incredible gift
to have both of you here
and to have you share the
wisdom you've both accumulated.
So thank you on
behalf of Google.
SUZY WELCH: Thank you.
LAZLO BOCK: The other thing
is I know just for this room
that you both offered to hang
around and say hello to folks,
anybody wants to
come up and chat.
And we have some
books back there
that you're free to
take, some others when
we run out that you're free
to purchase at a discount.
I imagine your hands aren't
completely sore and broken?
JACK WELCH: No, we're
happy to sign any books.
LAZLO BOCK: You can probably
get a few signatures.
But thank you, sincerely,
for sharing your message.
SUZY WELCH: Hey, thank
you for being here.
Thank you.
JACK WELCH: Laszlo, thank you.
LAZLO BOCK: Really
appreciate it.
Real pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]